I'm going  pit stop  hey guys I'm Dave the brand-new host  here at gamespot com joins day by Lucy  and I'm going to be kicking things off  with a show all about fallout first  episode is going to be a brief history  and the fallout universe but the second  episode is where we need your help so  we're going to be playing the first  fallout game obviously we need an  intrepid explorer to send out into the  wasteland so that's where we need your  help give us your ideas for character  name stats perks build gender everything  in the box below or tweet it at us i'm  at least James games I'm at a regular  Dave we will choose the best adventurer  from all the comments and tweaked and  the one that we use in the Let's Plays  will win a special prize to make sure  you stay tuned to gamespot com fallout  show is coming out on Thursday and stay  safe out there wasteland  you